[Music]
i love that show jeopardy and i've
mentioned this before i'm a huge fan of
jeopardy but i'm worried i'm starting to
think alex trebek has been hosting that
show
too long
i'm afraid he's starting to lose it yeah
take a look
i'll take three syllable words for 200
please
metallica made a whopper of a deal when
it paid over three billion dollars to
switch genders and become the one-armed
female peacock
what's the elephant bird lauren back to
you zoology for 800 please justin bieber
was struck by selena gomez's muslim
dwarf carpenter but recovered and
drooled in her older brother's bikini
bon appetit
talking about your basic duck
600 please
forget about benghazi the white house
says 66 of its customers are boisterous
violent russian redneck f holes who
fight off jewish vampires by arousing
napoleon's 12-inch man hammer
called a tall boy
take first name's the same for 200
please
to show remorse after murdering his wife
chris brown has merged with al qaeda to
develop this kid's game where you wear a
blindfold and drive a car with darth
vader's divorce papers from new york to
san francisco
chris what is it no
okay
lauren
no
we'll take a break
[Music]
i think i got that last one though